Hello, Adrian, how are you?
OK, how are you?
I'm good. So how's it going?
Yeah.
Oh, fine.
Or the same. I just had a 30 day check in with Grayson. I'm going to do the one with Abner on Wednesday since he'll be out on Tuesday. But
Yeah, everything's looking okay.
Okay, great. Any area where you think they need to work on, maybe increasing the ticket count or the utilization part, or you still want them to go slow?
Yeah, yeah, for.
Yeah, for sure. I'd like to see them go through and start picking up tickets. I think what they've been doing right or lately is just going and picking up one ticket, working that, and then probably picking up another couple, another ticket or so, and then working that one. I just talked about this with Grayson. I'd like to see him go out
Yes.
pick probably 5 to 10 tickets up, work through those, pick it up, pick up another 5 to 10 tickets, work through those. Like looking at it right now, Grayson has five tickets.
Abner has 13.
Again, even like Santino keeps a pretty low ticket count, which really isn't a, you know, a huge thing. But like the other day, we had a lot of alerts hanging out there and I would have liked to have seen them pick up some more. So Kris and I just went through and assigned a bunch of stuff to them. So I'd like to see them start picking up more tickets. And then also,
OK.
You know, we are in the, you know, the 30 days and they've been averaging probably around an hour, an hour and a half of customer time. And I just told Grayson that I'd like to see, you know, starting tomorrow or next week, probably 3 to 4 hours of customer time minimum.
Yeah.
for the next, you know, 30 days, once he hits 60 days, four to five hours, and then after, you know, 60 to 90 days, five to six. But, you know, realistically, we should be at full capacity by then.
Sure.
Any number of tickets we have in mind, like this is something they should pick at least a day, like at least 10 tickets a day or at least 15 tickets A day.
I think I think it's really there's a lot of variables behind that. So it's going to depend on how much stuff is out there, you know, what they already have on their plate, how they're doing, you know, closing out the tickets that they're picking up. I mean, I would say they probably should have somewhere between like 10 to 15 tickets assigned to them at any given time.
Key.
And then really, once they get really into the groove of things, I'd say like somewhere between like 15 to 25 tickets.
Okay.
is typically how we work through that. And that's about where all the other technicians are at as well.
I have Sterling with me, he wants to say hi.
Hey, buddy.
Hey, Idiot.
The.
Hey, Adrian, how are ya?
Good to see you. How are you?
Not too bad, not too bad about you.
Not too bad, man. We miss you. We hope that you're doing alright.
Yeah, I'm doing quite well. Just uh, I'm working on project stuff.
Very nice. Well, it was good to see you, buddy. Hope everything's doing good.
Same, same. I see that you have three new people, which I think you're going to train. Yeah, they're great.
Yeah.
They're doing good, but yeah, we we miss you though, that's for sure.
Okay.
I do the same. I was like, spend almost four years there, but yeah, I miss you guys.
I know all the other guys do as well.
Yeah, Kip Kip is gonna take care of them, all three of them. He's gonna sit on it, he's gonna sit on his head on their head and ask them to complete their work.
Of course, I know he will.
I know he will.
Alright, that's good seeing you. Bye.
You too, buddy.
Blake.
Bye.
Yeah.
So, he also sits straight behind Grayson and Abner and Sentinel, so he also helps them whenever he can, or he has time, so yeah, taking care of things, no problem.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very nice. It's good seeing them.
I felt bad because I, when like it was his last day and I got slammed doing other stuff, I just want to like shoot him a message or give him a call real quick. And he's like, oh, well, his accounts were deactivated. So I'm like, oh, okay. Well, I'm sure I'll talk to him eventually. And there we go. There it was.
Yeah.
Right, right.
Okay, and one more thing I would like to ask, Ketan, I know we talked about this earlier as well. Is there any way I can get access to why it is dashboard?
Only read only maybe just to see how many tickets are there and how they are picking up the tickets and all.
Probably not.
No.
Yeah, let me, when I asked, it wasn't a hard no, it was kind of like a soft no. Let me ask again and try to push that a little bit more. And then I'll see what I can do on that.
Yeah.
No, no problem.
I'm only asking because they are they are new and being considering Shrivastava getting off boarded next week. So just wanted to have more visibility on their boards. So that was the only reason.
Kip.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll see what I can do.
Okay, sure, no problem.
Let's quickly jump into the presentation then and let's see what they have done in the past week. Are you able to see my screen?
I sure can.
Great. Once again, welcome to our weekly business review. This is for the last week, starting May 11th till May 15th. No change in the agenda. It's the same. Check-in highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, move forward and recap. These are some highlights. Good feedback for Shiraj and Centino.
They are doing well.
We already talked about gradually reducing Sharad's ticket count, so that that can be relocated to Kris and Abdur.
And Grayson and Abner have completed their trainings and now they have already started working on the tickets. Shirage will be uploaded on 29th May and positive CSAT received for Shirage and sent in over the month of April. So as this month is also going to end from next.
month beginning, you will get the CSAT for all four engineers, including Shiraj, because he completed this month with you, and also for Abner and Grayson as well.
Yep.
Got it.
And here is the action tracker. The first one you can consider not relevant. And the second one, proactive board reviews for Santino, Adrian, Grayson. Keeping a close eye on them in terms of their utilization and tickets count.
And we'll keep on doing the same till July.
These were some ITBD recommended KPIs we discussed.
And we will circle back on this one once we have all three on track in terms of their utilization and tickets count. In performance analysis, this is for Sentino. His average had been 73%.
It has increased a bit based on our last connect.
And this is the ticket data for Centino. You worked on 63 tickets and closed almost all of them.
and mostly doing RMM alerts.
This is for Shiraj. It's been always been consistent. I've been at seventy-eight percent.
And this is the ticket data for Shrivastava. We wrote on 125 tickets and closed 89 with the ticket closure of 71 percent.
This is for Grayson. So he, his average billable utilization had been 17%. So mostly varied from 9% to max 27%. So, but he's picking up the pace. So.
And this is his ticket count. He worked on 29 tickets and closed 14 in the last week, makes the ticket closure of 46 percent.
Moving on to Abner, he was on PT on Monday and...
His average utilization for these four four days had been twenty-two percent.
And this is the ticket data for Evner. He worked on 23 tickets and closed 12. And that makes his closure rate at 49%.
So way forward again, we will be closely doing the board reviews with Santino, Kris, and Ebner to identify any gaps and proactively fix them.
And we'll continue to support all three in picking up the pace, as we discussed, to start meeting the utilization and ticket closure targets in the coming weeks and months.
Okay.
This is the game by design. This is Build It Live. So have you registered for Build It?
Still, still talk with Daniel about that.
So, I'm still talking with Daniel about that on, on if I can get out there or not.
I'm sorry?
Okay. Okay.
Okay, okay, sure, no problem. Any questions to let us know?
Okay.
This is a team GPS or in-house tool and that's it. Any other question, any other suggestion, feedback?
No. So we'll be doing, I'll be doing a 30 day check in with Abner next week and just going to pretty much reiterate the same things I did with Grayson today. You know, go out there, start picking up more tickets, receive more hours and then we will
Yeah.
Figure that out from there.
Yeah, and do check with your team regarding the dashboard if that can be done. So otherwise, no problem.
Yep.
Yeah, so thank you, Adrian, for joining this call today, and have a wonderful rest of the day and week.
You got it. You too, Bob. See ya.
Yeah. Thank you. Bye.